Art, as it has been said, is often subjective.
Whether it’s a sculpture, an oil painting
from the Renaissance, a renowned work of literature,
a digitally drawn webcomic or an insightful
animated YouTube video about SCP Foundation
lore, the deeper meaning behind a piece of
art can often change depending on the individual
observing it.
Sometimes, an artist intentionally makes the
message of their artwork clear, hoping to
have its meaning be unmistakable to any and
all that might see it.
Other times, such a meaning can be more ambiguous,
harder to decipher without some serious thought.
But either way, art is an important way that
human beings interpret the world around us.
It can be a reflection of emotions, experiences,
history and every new creation is as legitimate
a piece of art as the last.
But even with that being said, there may be
no piece of art that is a better reflection
of the world around us than SCP-804.
Or, to use its alternative title, the World
Without Man.
As you might have already guessed, SCP-804
is an art installation.
Or at the very least, it is what’s left
of an art installation.
The piece itself which was unveiled in Alaska,
was created by a group of artists known by
the name ‘Unelmat Paremmasta Maailmasta’,
A Finnish phrase which translates to ‘Dreams
of a Better World’ in English.
A fitting, highly appropriate name for the
group that created SCP-804, given the subject
of the piece.
All that remains of the artwork itself is
a portion of a once larger statue, sculpted
to resemble the shape of a globe.
Following extensive examination by the SCP
Foundation’s researchers, this globe has
been determined to most likely be a re-creation
of our very own Planet Earth.
Originally, this globe was a large, clear
model of Earth that also featured a number
of smaller globes and video equipment inside
of it.
It appears then that this art installation
may have been intended to function as a projector
of sorts, displaying varying images of scenes
from around the world.
These images would have primarily focused
on deserted and run down areas of human society,
such as abandoned buildings and decaying landmarks.
The art piece seems to have depicted how even
when we reshape our world and build cities,
we can damage the planet’s fragile ecosystem.
This is especially prevalent when the things
we build are then later left empty, buildings
rotting away, structures neglected to waste;
This mass destruction of nature, all in vain.
These images would then have been contrasted
with projections that show parts of the natural
world that have yet to be touched by human
beings, serene, beautiful places like corners
of the Amazon rainforest or the deepest stretches
of our oceans.
The message of the piece?
Well, we can only speculate, but it seems
as if it played a role in highlighting the
difference between the modern and natural
world.
So, what could be so important about one leftover
piece of a statue?
How about this: when it was first unveiled,
SCP-804 was able to produce a massive destructive
force, one in which plenty of people were
present to witness.
The Foundation has uncovered a number of documents
about ‘World Without Man’ from the artists’
website, when they stepped in to clear up
what happened after SCP-804 was revealed.
Among those present when the piece was displayed
were an audience of prominent environmental
activists who were well known throughout the
world for their efforts to alert people to
the threats facing our environment, and would
likely be the ones that the message of World
Without Man would resonate with the most.
Of course, we doubt the SCP Foundation is
all that interested in the artistic value
of SCP-804, or its message of protecting the
environment for that matter.
What happened next was probably more likely
to be what caught their interest.
From the moment it was activated, SCP-804’s
destructive properties were unleashed, and
it is still unclear if this was intentional
or not.
Had the members of Unelmat Paremmasta Maailmasta
planned to unfurl chaos at the revealing of
their masterpiece, or was World Without Man
sabotaged by someone who disagreed with its
deeper meaning?
It’s hard to say, the only thing the Foundation
knows for certain is that no one survived.
Anyone present during the incident was killed
where they stood, and those responsible for
creating SCP-804 either went into hiding or
perished themselves.
When activated, the smaller globes within
SCP-804’s larger one begin to rotate, causing
the display of its destructive and anomalous
properties.
The sculpture itself causes any man-made devices
or artifacts within a one hundred meter radius
to stop working.
Everything from phones and tablets, to clothing,
plastic, buildings, and even synthetic chemical
compounds will begin to deteriorate, decay
and even disintegrate.
If something is more advanced than a sharpened
stick of wood, SCP-804 can destroy it.
The longer World Without Man remains active,
the wider its area of effect, and the stronger
its destructive power will be.
However, its ability to destroy any man-made
object is always strongest closer to the source,
right next to the globe of the sculpture.
Sounds pretty inconvenient to be subjected
to losing your clothes and personal belongings
if you stand too close, but still harmless,
right?
Wrong.
SCP-804 also has an adverse, destructive effect
on human beings.
Tissue cells will also deteriorate in the
same way if they are within the radius of
World Without Man.
However, this happens much slower than when
the sculpture disintegrates man-made matter.
People standing too close will be painfully
and excruciatingly broken down, cell by cell.
A victim of SCP-804 will gradually lose body
mass, bit by bit, until only their skeleton
remains.
But it does not stop there.
The effects of the anomalous art piece will
continue even after death, dissolving bone,
organs, muscle, and marrow into their most
basic atomic components, until truly nothing
remains.
Interestingly, there are ways to survive an
encounter with the anomalous effect of SCP-804.
The first is to, well, not be a human being.
Anything non-human, including all forms of
animal and plant life, will be left unharmed
by the sculpture.
So, if you can somehow think of a quick way
to transform yourself into a bird, or a hydrangea,
you would manage to escape unscathed, in theory
at least.
Speaking of escaping, though, even if you
were caught in SCP-804’s area of effect,
there is a chance you could still survive
if you got far enough away before your entire
body was turned to dust.
Though drastic, it is possible to recover
from World Without Man’s human tissue damage
given the proper circumstances and volume
of medical care.
During the SCP Foundation’s testing, those
who have survived, have suffered symptoms
similar to those of extreme and prolonged
starvation.
Creating a sculpture that sends out a shockwave
capable of destroying all man-made materials
and any human beings within one hundred meters
of it’s source, is certainly one hell of
a way to get the deeper message of your artwork
across.
But that might have you thinking, if SCP-804
is a piece of art, and it was created by the
members of an art collective, then isn’t
World Without Man also technically man-made?
And you would be correct in thinking that.
Through prolonged testing of the device, the
SCP Foundation has determined that SCP-804
is not immune to its own destructive effects.
Since its first activation, and over the course
of the Foundation’s rigorous examination
of it, the sculpture’s capabilities have
become impaired.
However, this does not make it any less dangerous.
If someone was somehow able to repair SCP-804,
perhaps reunite it with the statue it was
originally a part of, then the threat it would
pose to the modern world would be astronomical.
How bad would the damage be?
Well, let’s put it this way; if SCP-804
was able to remain fully active without suffering
its own effects, then this anomalous artwork
could easily wipe any and all traces of humanity
from the face of Planet Earth… in a matter
of weeks.
You could be forgiven for thinking that destroying
man-made artifacts and disintegrating human
tissue was the worst that SCP-804 can do,
but you would be wrong yet again.
The Foundation’s top researchers have theorized
that World Without Man also possessed some
form of memetic effect, that SCP-804 is able
to mentally influence people, possibly creating
a compulsion among those who view it.
However, they are still uncertain of this,
and testing is currently focused on if this
effect has also been weakened by SCP-804’s
gradual decay.
But back to when this destructive piece of
art was first discovered.
Unelmat Paremmasta Maailmasta had unveiled
World Without Man at an art show in Alaska.
Around five minutes after SCP-804 initially
activated, a nearby remote town in northern
Alaska was the first to feel the effects.
The residents were panicked, calling for emergency
services - After all, wouldn’t you be afraid
if you realized that you were starting to
disintegrate, along with your home and all
your possessions?
Unfortunately, the town was too remote of
a location for anyone to properly respond.
A single light aircraft was the first on the
scene, and the pilot witnessed firsthand as
the entire town was rapidly wiped out.
By the time the Foundation heard about the
situation and dispatched its agents to the
location, there was nothing left.
Not one home, nor any living person.
SCP-804 had been active for almost eight straight
hours, and the nearby Alaskan town had been
wiped clean of any and all traces of human
civilization.
The Foundation’s agents traced the epicenter
of SCP-804’s destructive effect back to
where it had been unveiled, only to discover
that survivors from the nearby town had gathered
around what was left of the sculpture.
Many of them were already suffering from hypothermia,
as well as being severely affected by the
device in other ways.
Somehow, these survivors were being compelled
to approach SCP-804 and push the globe within
to reactivate its effect.
If one died, another would step forward from
the group to take their place.
Those around the sculpture would cheer and
encourage them to maintain the anomalous artwork,
praising them for keeping it running despite
what SCP-804 was doing to them.
Under the orders of an O5 council member,
the Foundation agents on site opened fire
on the crowd, their bullets disintegrating
from the statue’s effect but still managing
to cause lethal wounds.
As the globe stopped spinning, the effects
of SCP-804 ended and the agents were able
to move in and secure the sculpture.
Many of the survivors then opted to lie down
in the snow, letting their injuries and the
cold kill them.
Any that were arrested by the Foundation refused
to respond to questioning.
Given that any Foundation facility would be
man-made in nature, it was decided that SCP-804
would be best left where it was, allowing
the Alaskan cold to freeze its machinery.
A handful of Foundation guards were left on
site as well, just in case anyone decided
to come looking for World Without Man and
try to reactivate the anomalous piece of art.
Additionally, the Foundation wanted the remains
of the device kept away from their facilities
until they could figure out if or how it had
compelled people to keep it active.
Doctor Johannes Sorts of the SCP Foundation
investigated the memetic properties of SCP-804,
and according to his findings “There is
nothing especially virulent or dangerous about
SCP-804's memetic properties.
Only a few select personality types have any
desire to re-activate the device…
We've been looking at this all wrong, there
is no magical compulsion that could drive
so many people to destroy themselves.
There does not need to be.”
The artist and activist group Unelmat Paremmasta
Maailmasta had created a device capable of
wiping out all traces of human life on Earth.
It could turn buildings and people to dust,
making any that were left keep it spinning
no matter if it killed them.
It was made to represent an ideal, the cure
for the planet from the disease of humanity.
But why would these activists unleash it on
a town full of innocent people?
If they knew this machine had the potential
to wipe out all human life on Earth, why activate
it, killing themselves too?
The answer is simple: because they wanted
to.
They intended to send a message.
But the real question is, are we smart enough
to listen to it?
Now go check out “SCP-2317 - The Devourer
of Worlds / A Door to Another World” and
“SCP XK Class End of the World Scenarios
Explained” for more anomalies that could
bring humanity to its knees!